[Music]
they're ripping us left and right just
take them to mcdonald's and go back to
the negotiating table seriously
she's shocked that i picked her no it's
like in a state of shock
go ahead sir can you stay quiet mr
president-elect go ahead and you say can
you ask any questions the
president-elect can you give us
don't be attacking us can you give us a
question don't be
actually felt good i felt water on my
face i said where the hell is that
they may be doing that on purpose let's
find out if they're friend or foe
and if their phone let's take care of
those son of a [ __ ] but one of the
things i noticed tonight
and i've known hillary for a long time
is this is the first time ever
ever that hillary is sitting down
and speaking to major corporate leaders
and not getting paid for it that's true
i'll tell you what cnn should be ashamed
of itself having you
working for them you are a rude terrible
person you shouldn't be working
for cnn go ahead mr president you
repeatedly
over the course of time just sit down
please i'm not in your position i'm
asking you if you've got something
i'm asking you would you do that if you
were in my position
if you would do that you should never be
in this position
that laptop was produced by russia here
we go again
russia russia russia here we go again
can you imagine what they must think of
and these people are crazy
and he is a wonderful guy i like him he
just happens to have a very bad arm
[Music]
[Applause]
here's a bed arm
[Music]
the head of google who's a great
gentleman said
called us and he apologized i don't know
where the press got their fake news but
they got it someplace but
as you know this is from google they put
out a release and
uh you guys can figure it out yourselves
and how that got out and i'm sure you'll
apologize
but it would be great if we could really
give the news correctly are we so
so wonderful is the mic
ready as
roberts go ahead john no no john roberts
guy
cnn's fake news i don't think i don't
take questions
cnn is fake news i don't take questions
from john roberts of fox
[Applause]
[Music]
they used to write nothing about me now
i averaged probably about four or five
stories a day on the front page
someday they're gonna give me a good one
watch
it might be tomorrow
you